tiffany in the kids is landing here in
south africa tomorrow and
i'm excited but i have so much to do
the original plan that i discussed with
tiffany was
daniel was just going to sleep on the
couch until a few days ago and then i
decided no
i'm going to build him his own room his
own space he will be happy
make it more home-like why so big
what do you mean so big my garage
actually has a lot of space so i just
decided to get some drywalling and
extend it and close it up and build the
room for daniel
this is definitely gonna be all-nighter
why do so much
effort say they're gonna stay here for
maybe a few days or a month or a half
month
i don't want daniel to say i missed the
u.s you know i missed this missed that
i want him to be excited when he comes
to come so
let me tell you one thing the only time
frame that they will go back
or that i will allow them to is when
either the visa expires
that's three months and then i'll extend
it with another three months
that's six months or
the other option is my visa gets
approved everything goes through and i
fly back with him yeah but that's
i don't want my family to leave again
hell no
i haven't seen my family in almost a
year
i feel i deserve having them here i
deserve having carly running around
daniel's screaming
it's been long enough you think i'll
allow them to come for a few weeks
hell no no someone's in for a surprise
that'll tell you
tiffany she only wants to come for a few
weeks but we are not on the same page
today
i want them to stay as long as possible
it's about making them comfortable and
showing them i can
make a home yeah they will see they can
live here actually and they will love it
yeah i can show i can be a dad i can
take over the fatherly
role i can be the man of the house so
you're going to tell us she's going to
stay longer
hopefully i don't need to tell her
hopefully she'll just want to stand up
that's my whole thing if my visa
should get declined my family could be
on the line of breakup the whole family
has to get
a whole mindset of living in south
africa
otherwise there's no family the fact of
the matter is
if stephanie doesn't want to move to
south africa i'll force her to
i'm not going to be away from my kids
again that long